[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma été je crois que vous
avez réuni devant nous l'a beaucoup de
choses qui permettent de faire
certainement un plat très traditionnel
et très bon c'est la familiale
certainement une chose un peu anciennes
je ne devine pas trop qu'est-ce que vous
avez l'intention de faire en réalité
et bien c'est un plat alsacien et qui
s'appelle le pk au phare j'espère que je
me prononcerai bière que je le dis bien
et là parce que vous et moi prononcé un
alsacien on n'est pas sûr qu'on fait
très bien même si on sait henri louchart
donneront pas ce qu'ils sont et ils
savent tous que c'est un excellent plat
et qu'on va essayer de le faire
exactement comme vous alors nous
pardonneront si la prononciation n'est
pas bien oui parce que maïté il faut
quand même dire que dans le sud ouest on
a tendance quelquefois être un peu
chauffe chauvin on nous l'a reproché
quelquefois oui mais en fait mais dans
toute la france toutes les régions de
france il ya des spécialités merveilleux
maintenant et nous adorons les découvrir
et il faut toujours les essayer faut
être très curieux voilà en cuisine c'est
un plaisir d'être curieux alors vous
allez faire seulement ça vous ferez
aussi mais on va faire des rognons de
veau au sauternes passer davantage de
chez nous voilà alors qu'est ce qu'il
vous faut pour ces deux recettes on va
tout mélanger la lnah le produit en
faire l'inventaire les deux recettes
il faut du vin blanc d'alsace à ça va de
soi il faut du sauternes de chez nous ça
va de soi de l'armagnac
après de là à l'ardeur de dix jours de
dijon autres régions ont fait tout le
tour est allé surfer le taux des gentils
veille du poireau de l'échalote de des
carottes des navets des pommes de terre
de laurier là ici on a un petit peu de
discernement fait avec du persil nous on
avait surfé aujourd'hui du ter les clous
de girofle un peu de girofle oublier les
défauts de l'ail des petits oignons bien
évidemment les rognons ça vient ça vient
bien après les roses ou des oignons des
réunions très joli très jolie villa il
faut trois cadres alors attendez là il
faut pas trop vite
oui ça c'est du porte ça c'est du boeuf
et ceux de la news 3 vient de
différentes et là c'était un de pied de
porc en habiller le coach aura pied de
cochon et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en
premier
on va faire marie dc3 viande ces quatre
viennent le pied dans du vin d'alsace
évidemment et oui pas trop d'où un bon
feeling ou un sylvaner ça va être
délicieux ça n'entre bouteille a passé
la voile à lanoraie loin de là mais on
fait l'effort
en fait tout est faux nos conseils ont
rien fait et là je vais mettre tout ce
qu'il faut dans ses regrets et je
rajouterais les viandes
ap alors du sel bien entendu du poivre
non mais t'es n'exagère pas quand même
sur une hausse de taux d'audience se
voit que de girofle et opiacés
après du thym du teint qui est superbe
et parce qu'il est frais voilà du thym
du cerfeuil cerfeuil la du laurier se
sont déjà délicieux parce que le zinc ou
jamais été un petit peu et on va mettre
la viande parce que ça ça va bien
reprendre goût et de l'est et même le
christ et en premier le pied de porc qui
le portent sont là ça c'est le livre de
beurre l'agneau dans ce problème là
derrière
l'agneau et vous un accord aux deux
petits morceaux l'a essayé et on va
attendre maïté là assez longtemps pensé
longtemps il faut lorsque son mari de
bien bien bien 24 heures au passé et
maïté la viande a vraiment changé de
couleur et d'aspect l'église hop tu peux
maintenant dire eh oui mais elle est
parfait mais aussi que vous allez en
faire maintenant alors je vais couper la
viande en morceaux en morceaux voile
là et vous voulez que je vois là par les
légumes pendant ce temps les lakers les
problèmes du peu mais on assez gros
morceau vous m'avez expliqué oui je
voulais prépare on va faire des morceaux
carré directeur du caert est qu il faut
bien prendre des trois viandes
jean-louis parce qu'il faut tout
mélanger le beurre ça c'est le port oui
monsieur je vous prendrai toutes les
caisses que vous mettrez en premier dans
le fond de votre terrine le pied
le pied d'abord là et maintenant le
mouton va mettre un petit peu alors le
biais pour commencer à nouveau coupé non
non non je sais qu'il y aura tous ne
vous inquiétez parole alors les trois
viandes sont là je mets tout de suite le
pied dans le sens de la théorie dans le
fond de la terrine après une couche de
chaque viande le légume
eh bien je vais faire un petit dériveur
le nord une couche de légumes
on n'a pas tout mettre d'un coup je
crois même sûr que non quelques paroles
en n2 il n'est pas coupé lannion - ou
copier peu pathétique en morceaux de
verre de l'iphone de pommes de terre des
carottes
vous avez des gousses d'ail qui vous
attendent vous y avez pensé
j'ai poussé constants alors que vous
avez mis encore un petit peu d'herbe
je vais remettre je vais remettre aux
partenaires moi parce qu'il ya déjà le
goût de jeu avec du cerfeuil un petit
peu de navin et ainsi de suite et on
continue au monde
vous terminerez par l'avion nous parle
et légumes var et légumes
là vous en donne donc alors encore un
peu il va mettre carottes pommes de
terre de nouveau un bois robien fermé on
a
et là un mot niort on n'a pas besoin de
rajouter de thym le laurier
non pas du tout parce qu'il ya là dans
la marinade et maintenant je vais mettre
le jus est justement dans la merde voilà
très parfumée ray parfumées ou il ya
tout eu
et c'est bon c'est terminé mais le
témoin en cuir pas du tout alors
maintenant on va faire la pâte et la
pâte pour quoi faire
vous allez comme un maillon glay c'est
pour soulever le couvercle qu'est-ce que
vous avez mis dans cette pâte roues très
facile la farine et de l'autre tout
simplement si vous croyez que ça va être
donc simplement ça ne marche pas ces
juges voulaient manger par du tout c'est
juste pour céder le couvercle a annoncé
jean entre nantes voilà exactement le
rouleau à pâtisserie 1
et pas besoin d'aller l'acheter chez le
commerce moi je vois que ça va très bien
avec l'amiante en a l'air ces bières ça
fait le couvercle maïté racer 2 couverts
comme pour un bail anglais la langue
elle pas en visionnant tout à l'heure
mais on a très bien là mais c'est pas
pareil c'est pas pareil parce qu'après
voilà ce qu'on fait c'est juste qu'on
pouvait découper
oui voilà
et vous allez mettre le couvercle par là
dessus et c'est ça qui va serrer le
couvercle à la vapeur ne va pas pouvoir
s'échapper comment vous allez maintenant
8 3 heures de ta à four à 200° oui et
une heure on va baisser à 180 pour que
sa religion de tout en seulement quatre
heures de cuisson et bien mérité je
crois que c'est pour ça que ça porte se
nou paka au phare c'est parce qu'on le
faisait dans le four de boulanger
voilà où on a plus le vouloir j'ai alors
fait la voix là et elle a pendant que ça
cuit il va falloir faire autre chose
grèveront yorosso terme vous les faites
entier ah non je vais les escales en
plus avec un couteau un couple bien
d'être les futures sur ce qu'on fait là
pour un an parce que je ne vous avais
mis à chauffer dans l'ordre et faire
revenir des échalotes
oui et les rognons je vais les faire et
comment dit presque bleu clair que vous
êtes juste essayer
ils les saisir dans un peu de graisse de
canard vraisemblablement chaude un
bouquet de roses et partiront cuit dans
la trop élevé
demain voilà yacht
saler poivrer bien entendu qu'on joue
toujours au jour le jour
alors je vais me taire parce que
l'assiette
voilà ils sont juste de conduire au
comme avait dit dans la vallée garder un
saut directement ces bons vins depuis
peu mais bien car depuis ce processus
alors non on comprend pourquoi je vais
faire venir des echards ou que je vais
remettre dans cette pause déjeuner ou
chauffour on est au chaud dans ce four
là là là bas et je vais mais échalotes
en évitant de mettre la gr parce qu'il
ya déjà dégradé la voilà vous allez me
passer l'armagnac
on va flamber un petit brun
là
hélas interne
déjà maintenant dans cette langue
on attend un petit peu ça va continuer à
cueillir et maintenant on va laisser
mijoter tout ça oui pratiquement à sec
et on remettra des rognons après cela
vous convient d'arrêter ça va c'est
assez réduit c'est presqu'un sexe est
bon alors je vais être la crème fraîche
d'abord la la peau quand même oui il en
faut bien un tout petit peu et je vais
me remettre de la moutarde qui devraient
être bonnes mains ça devrait c'est bon
c'est très bon une cuillère de moutarde
ou stocker et très parfumé général un
petit pas de plus et nous rognons qu'on
as encore des sous mais qui sont encore
saignant ils sont pas cuits il faudra
remettre un petit peu dans cette bonne
source
il voit l'avenir de l'est lui rentrer
dedans voilà et nous nous restera plus
qu'à présenter les plats oui c'est
l'heure de vérité
là je suis anxieuse maïté mais pas plus
que moi et il va sortir ce couvercle
d'un seul coup vous croyez bien je crois
que tout est bien scellé non ça va bien
où ça sent bon là dedans
voilà alors là on a nos viandes
on a confiance on a nos légumes j'espère
que c'est comme ça on va sortir ça c'est
peut-être un peu cuit un peu plus enfin
on demande l'indulgence de nos amis
d'alsace
on a voulu dans la robe images on me dit
c'est bon c'est bon on va sortir le
dessus la rega sont délicats encore du
tout va bien ah oui c'est bien si c'est
bon là c'est bien mais j'aurais jamais
cru que ce accusé s'il vient à non mais
c'est délicieux où les parfums sont
restés enfermés à du jus de dentelle
rien et puis à nous renier en maïté un
plat raffiné et keller absolument
succulent se dégoûter c'est divin je
vous crois sur parole alors on a le
place à milliane qui se mange tout
simplement avec une salade verte
on a nos rognon à la moutarde au
sauternes à l'armagnac à la crème à
plein son délicieux vont et tomates
c'est assez pour faire joli c'est pour
nous mettre en appétit pour la
décoration
alors à vous nous dit après avoir essayé
si vous avez aimé ou si nous avons fait
des erreurs
au revoir à bientôt au revoir nos envies
d'alsace
[Musique]